- Welcome back y'all,
it's our Rad Dad Hour.
Joel McHale is with us!
(crowd cheering)
You can catch him in "Stargirl" on the CW,
and in "Crime Scene Kitchen" on Fox.
Also with us is an entire
audience of super rad dads.
(crowd cheers)
Like mothers, fathers face
trials and tribulations
all the time.
Sometimes, y'all handle it
with deliberate delicacy.
Other times, well, not
so much, just like mamas.
I know some of the guys in the audience
want to pick Joel's brain,
so let's get started.
Where is Seth?
- The guys with poor judgment.
- [Seth] Right here, hey.
- Hey what's up, Seth?
- [Joel] Hey, what's up, super
hipster dad with his hoodie?
- [Kelly] I like it.
- [Joel] Hoodie hybrid jean jacket.
- [Seth] Exactly, it's
all attached, one piece.
How's it going, guys?
I'm Seth.
My wife, Ashley, and I have a son, Emmett,
who's turning one in
just a couple of weeks.
- Oh wow, young.
- [Seth] Yeah, he's a
very, very high energy kid.
He's kind of an adrenaline junkie.
- Wow.
- [Seth] He has a little toy
car that we push him around on,
and his favorite part is when
we crash him into things.
He can't get enough of that, so.
- [Kelly] The foreshadowing is so scary
for you right now, my man.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- [Joel] It's great. He's
gonna do great in Los Angeles.
- [Seth] Yeah, a little
Dom Toretto in the making.
So, I usually am pretty lenient
in how much space I give him
to explore that danger zone,
but my wife is a bit more protective
and we butt heads about it a lot.
- Is it her first kid,
like it's your first kid?
- [Seth] It's our first kid, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, that's
probably why she is.
- [Joel] Yeah.
- It creates conflict with your wife...
- [Seth] Yeah it does. We butt heads
on trying to figure out exactly
where to draw that line.
- [Kelly] That's a hard line.
- [Joel] I think it's
case by case. You're like,
"Your son put his head through the wall,
and let's not do that tomorrow."
(laughter)
Right?
- Yeah, it's fair.
- [Kelly] But I'm just
saying, there is a line.
It's kind of, it's just, I don't know,
it depends on the situation,
I will say as well as you,
like it depends on the
situation, but that's different.
It is. When it's the first
kid, a lot of mamas are like
so protective 'cause. Now
if you have another one,
trust me, it'll lessen each time.
- Right. If you have a third,
you won't even remember the first's name.
(crowd laughing and clapping)
You're doing the right thing.
Let him do his thing
and be slightly concerned the whole time.
- [Kelly] I think it's smart of you too,
to let him kind of be free and whatever,
'cause I love that my kids,
they learned fear naturally.
Like, do you know what I'm saying?
They were fine around one,
but around like two or three,
they were like, "wait, I
could like really get hurt."
Like, they learned it naturally
instead of me imposing that upon them,
'cause you don't wanna teach that, right?
- Yeah yeah yeah, I want him to be able to
get hurt and get himself back up.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's normal
- [Joel] Yeah, I'd get him some fireworks
for his second birthday.
- [Kelly] Get him some knee pads,
- And a lighter
- And a helmet, he'll be fine. (laughs)
- [Joel] You're a great dad, rad dad!
Thank you, rad dad.
- [Kelly] Thank you Seth.
- All right so up next,
Mark in our house seats
has a question.
So, what's going on with you, Mark?
- Yeah, I've got four daughters.
- [Kelly] Oh my! God bless!
- Age 12, 9, 16, and 4.
- [Joel] Mark, we're
just clapping for you.
- [Mark] Yeah. We were
sitting there the other day,
my wife and I were having a conversation
around what's about to happen to us
and what we realized was;
our oldest is about to be a teenager
and for the next 15 years,
we're about to have at
least one teenage daughter
in our house.
So my question for you, Joel,
is you have boys.
What kind of advice do
you have for me, to...
I've already lost my hair,
so we're past that point,
but to help understand where
boys are coming from in 2022.
What can I tell my girls to
scare them off from dating
for a while?
- Hm. Well, if I were you, I would leave.
Just get out. I'd move
to somewhere tropical.
Boy, well, I have... Okay, so...
- Four girls.
- [Joel] Four girls.
Clearly, you are a good dad.
It sounds like you're
raising good people, right?
- [Mark] Trying my best.
- Can I say something real quick, though?
Cause I think it's so
interesting how men will always
be worried about the boys,
but I think you're...
You and your wife are
gonna do a good enough job
to teach them to know the difference
between a tool and a nice guy.
You know what I'm saying?
I think that you should
be fine by the time
they're old enough to start dating,
whenever that is. My
daughter, I told her 30.
But no, by the time they
start dating, you know,
have some pride in the
fact that you've probably
done a really great job parenting
and you've given her the tools to know
and be honest, like let's be
real, boys at that age, look,
they'll tell you anything. And
that's what I tell my people.
- [Joel] Yeah, and I think
Kelly's rule applies.
If you're not, if you haven't been a tool,
they're not going to date tools.
- I have friends that
have such great fathers
and they have, we always call them, like,
they have such a high
bar. And I'm always like,
"God, I don't know if anybody's
going to live up to that."
And they're like, "Okay. Well,
then I'll wait until they
will." And it's nice!
They have that confidence because they had
such great relationships with their dads
and they were shown what
a man should be like
in a relationship, and I think
if you do a good job at that,
you should be fine and trust them enough
to make a good decision.
- Thank you.
- Where is Jeff?
- [Joel] Hey, Jeff.
- So, I have two boys. One is
three and one is 18 months.
I love being a dad. It's the best.
They're so much fun. They're
the best toys I've ever had.
- [Joel] Here comes the but...
- [Jeff] But I'm in a situation, right?
So, bodily functions
are totally in play now
and poopy and peepee is
everything for the 3 year old.
We'll go to restaurants and he'll order.
"Hey, daddy, I want chicken
nuggets. I want fries,
milk, and hey, poopy, too."
And so now, the little one
who's just starting to talk,
his first words are poopy,
peepee. He's like cheerleading.
- It's the influence.
- It's the influence. I
think it's kind of funny.
My wife doesn't think it's as funny.
- [Kelly] I am your wife.
- [Joel] I am you.
- [Jeff] Joel, you have
older kids that are boys...
- No, we talk about farts all the time.
- [Jeff] That was my question.
- There's nothing wrong
with talking about farts
but if it's all you talk about,
the influence of the older
one with the younger one,
that's hard.
- I feel like what you're...
That the first basic...
in a human being, if you know
they have a sense of humor
that's the first thing
that they'll talk about
because it's inherently
funny for the entire
race of humanity, and so I
think it's still innocent
and it's clearly a weird thing
that's happening to them all the time.
It's hilarious the way God
put us together, right?
So, I think it's a good sign...
- I feel like you're
a little uncomfortable
talking about flatulence.
- Well, I just let one go.
(audience cheers)
- Save the penguins!
- [Joel] She's drawing the
line. I don't... Do you...
- [Kelly] I think you
kind of, okay, with that,
they're both so young that
it's still kind of cute.
- So leave poop in play,
is what we're gonna do?
- Poop is funny.
- [Joel] Yeah. And if they
can order it from McDonald's,
or wherever you were, see what happens.
- [Kelly] That's fantastic.
My thing is, my struggle is,
my little boy liked to play with it.
- Well.
- [Kelly] I would walk in and he--
- [Joel] Whoa, that's where
you guys are drawing the line?
- [Kelly] His crib would be
covered and he'd be like,
"Mommy, painted." I'm like, "no."
Yeah, do your kids do that?
- No. I'm gonna maybe stop there.
- [Kelly] Yeah then maybe
you stop complaining, Jeff!
- [Joel] Why don't you calm down?
- See, that's where your kids get it.
- That is.
- [Kelly] Thank you, Jeff!
- That's going all in. That's good.
- Okay, so we have one more question.
This is from a proud
papa in my band, y'all.
Kyle on the bass!
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] What's up, Kyle?
- What's happening?
- What's going on?
- [Kyle] Hey, Joel, how you doing?
So, your kids are a
little older than mine.
Mine are five and three.
I notice that when I'm
cooking them dinner,
the more TLC I put into it,
like if I'm making a quesadilla,
I pre-melt the cheese
and I grill it up with butter
and I get it all crispy.
And if I'm cutting fruit, like,
no brown spots in the fruit,
cause I know they won't touch that.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you want them to eat it.
- I want them to actually eat it.
So, I get it all pristine, I present it.
They won't even think
about eating it, right?
- [Kelly] It's so upsetting.
- Right. And then meanwhile,
if I just, the day I give up
and just throw them like a
bowl of Tostito's or something
and they just devour that,
so. I just want to know like,
how do I care less and get them to eat?
Or do you have meals that you recommend
when they were young like that?
- [Kelly] That's hard
because you do want your kids
to eat well but they don't
eat... my boy only eats beige.
Anything beige, I'm like,
he does not like anything
other than fries, he likes,
all beige.
- I, I mean, is that the kid
that was wiping everything everywhere?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, well, you know.
- [Kelly] There's a lot there.
There's a lot going on there.
- First of all...
- Touche.
- Congrats on your
Tostitos campaign coming up
(audience cheers)
and that's... Let's say,
you're doing the cooking,
which is really good. I
still meet dudes today
that are like, "I don't do that."
And I'm like, "You
shouldn't even live there."
And, well that's great. And, well,
this is, I think, secretly is
what's going to keep your kids
loving you forever and
coming home to visit you.
Because when they get
to wherever they are,
they go to college, away, they'll realize
how good the food was
and then they'll be like,
"Daddy, come make me things."
And they'll be 35 talking that
way and always stick around.
- So they will appreciate it in 13 years.
- [Kyle] In 13 to 20 years.
- [Joel] Yeah.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- [Kelly] It's all about the long game.
- Long game. I get it. I get it.
- But that...
- It's hard, food, with kids.
- Yes.
- Did you have a hard time with your boys?
- Oh, I make dinner for my kids each night
and one of them will, I
go, sit down if you would,
and he will lie down on the
floor, not touch anything,
and then have peanut
butter toast an hour later
and that will be the...
- [Kelly] My kid's is oatmeal.
He'll eat oatmeal, if, yeah...
But I have to put the foot
down. I don't know if y'all do.
I'm like, "This is dinner."
Like, I'm not a short order cook.
This is dinner, this is
what's happening, or oatmeal.
Like that's your option.
I'ma pop in that oatmeal
maple, whatever that you get.
- My 13 year old will be
like, "Yeah, but, Dad,
you're so good at it."
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And then just walk away.
- My kids will never tell
me I'm good at cooking.
Thank you, Kyle!
- [Joel] Kyle, thank you!
- Thanks guys. Keep it
up, Joel. Thank you.
- The fact that he's concerned about it...
- [Kelly] In 13 years,
you're gonna be great, man.
It's the long game.
All right, everybody. Thank you so much
for all the great questions.
When we come back, we'll
meet a father and son...